en los mecanismos de reacción de dos
necesitamos un alumno de alquilo y una
base fuerte en nuestro alumno de alquilo
el carbón o directamente enlazado al
halógeno se llama el carbono alfa y
todos los carbonos enlazados
directamente con el carbono alfa se
llaman carbonos beta y para que esta
reacción suceda
necesitamos un hidrógeno beta pero no
sólo eso sino que estos cuatro átomos
tienen que poder existir en un mismo
plano este hidrógeno y este carbono y
este otro carbono y el halógeno estos
cuatro átomos están en el mismo plano y
por eso estoy dibujando sus enlaces así
y todos los demás enlaces que no están
en el plano los estoy dibujando de estas
otras formas
además el hidrógeno y el halógeno tienen
que estar en lados opuestos si dibujo
una línea punteada sobre el enlace de
los dos carbonos el hidrógeno y el halo
que no tienen que estar en lados
distintos
esta configuración ponemos el prefijo
anti ok para que suceda esta reacción
necesitamos un hidrógeno y un halógeno
anti peri plan ares ok el halógeno y el
hidrógeno son anti porque están en lados
distintos y están en el mismo plano
ahora una cosa muy importante es que
este es un mecanismo concertado porque
suceden dos cosas al mismo tiempo llega
a la base y se lleva este protón y los
electrones de este enlace se van para
acá para formar un doble enlace al mismo
tiempo que los electrones de este enlace
se van con el halógeno así es que es un
mecanismo concertado y bueno los
electrones de este enlace
ahora están formando el doble enlace
entre estos dos carbonos y nuestro
producto es un al que no pero también
nos podemos fijar en la cinética química
si nos fijamos en la cinética de las
reacciones de eliminación de 2
la rapidez de la reacción es igual a la
constante de velocidad por la
concentración del sustrato a la primera
potencia y por cierto el sustrato es
nuestro valor o del kilo por la
concentración de la base elevada a la
potencia 1 aquí nos referimos a esta
base así es que tenemos aquí una
reacción de eliminación que depende
tanto de la concentración del sustrato
como de la concentración de la base y
por eso le llamamos e2e porque es una
reacción de eliminación que estamos
eliminando es una reacción de
eliminación y el 2 es porque este
mecanismo es bi molecular eso lo que
significa es que depende de la
concentración de dos moléculas la
concentración del sustrato y la
concentración de la base
digamos que aumentamos la concentración
del sustrato por un factor 2 estamos
duplicando la concentración del alumno
de al kilo y
digamos que también duplicamos la
concentración de la base entonces
estamos multiplicando la concentración
de la base por un factor de 2 si hacemos
eso si duplicamos estas dos
concentraciones qué es lo que sucede con
la velocidad de la reacción bueno pues
si hiciéramos esto tendríamos que la
velocidad de la reacción es igual a la
constante de velocidad por 2 elevado a
la 1 por la concentración del sustrato
por 2 elevado a la 1 por la
concentración de la base y aquí estamos
multiplicando por 2 elevado a la 1
porque estas concentraciones están
elevadas a la 1 y las estamos duplicando
entonces en total estamos aumentando la
velocidad de la reacción por un factor
de 2 por 2 o sea 4 si duplicamos la
concentración del sustrato y duplicamos
la concentración de la base aumentamos
la velocidad de la reacción por un
factor 4 entonces esta reacción se
parece a las reacciones sn 2
términos de la cinética química recuerda
que en el nombre s n 2 s 2 está ahí
porque también es una reacción be
molecular
pero bueno ahora vamos a ver un ejemplo
de una reacción 2 a la izquierda tenemos
nuestro alumno de alquilo el carbono
enlazado con nuestro halógeno es el
carbono alfa y todos los carbonos
enlazados con el carbono alfa son
carbonos beta aunque en este caso todos
nuestros carbonos beta son equivalentes
y en este caso nuestra base es una unión
hidróxido por lo que necesitamos una
fuente de añón es hidróxidos y este
mecanismo de reacción es 2 vamos a
empezar volviendo a dibujar nuestro
valor o del kilo y le ponemos sus pares
de electrones libres al bromo sabemos
que este mecanismo de reacción es
concertado y que sus dos pasos suceden
exactamente al mismo tiempo ponemos por
aquí nuestro a nyon hidróxido
y sabemos que el año ni hidróxido va a
llegar y se va a llevar uno de los
hidrógenos de un carbono beta así es que
voy a dibujar por aquí un hidrógeno beta
y al mismo tiempo que la unión hidróxido
llega y se lleva a este hidrógeno sus
electrones se pasan para acá para formar
un doble enlace entre estos dos carbonos
y exactamente al mismo tiempo los
electrones de este enlace se quedan en
el bromo y el bromo se va y como
producto obtenemos un al que no así es
que los electrones de este enlace se
pasaron para acá y ahora forman este
doble enlace
este es nuestro al que no ahora por otro
lado también tenemos nuestra unión
bromuro con su par de electrones extra y
su carga negativa podemos decir que los
electrones de este enlace se quedaron en
el bromo y los estamos representando en
este par de electrones ahora por otro
lado el a nyon hidróxido se llevó un
hidróxido y se volvió una molécula de
agua
si es que por acá también vamos a poner
nuestra molécula de agua claro que lo
que realmente nos interesa es la
formación de este al que no cuando
estábamos hablando acerca de la cinética
de la reacción dijimos que las
reacciones de dos se parecen mucho a las
reacciones sn 2 y que eso sucede porque
las dos son bi moleculares sin embargo
si nos fijamos en el sustrato esas dos
reacciones sn 2 y 2 son completamente
distintas por ejemplo las reacciones sn
2 no suceden si tienes un sustrato
terciario y no suceden por el
impedimento estético por acá tenemos
demasiado impedimento estético como para
que pueda suceder un ataque núcleo
físico si estuviéramos pensando que el
año ni hidróxido va a llegar y va a ser
un ataque núcleo físico a este carbono
sabemos que hay demasiado impedimento
estético como para que suceda eso porque
tenemos aquí
estos grupos metilo sin embargo si
pensar
en una reacción de eliminación de dos no
tenemos ese problema porque no
necesitamos que el avión hidróxido
llegue hasta este carbono lo único que
necesitamos es que se lleve algún protón
de alguno de los carbonos beta y
definitivamente si hay mucho espacio
como para que pueda suceder eso tal vez
ya quedó muy claro pero me parece que
con un vídeo podría llegar a quedar más
claro todavía y así puedes ver las
diferencias entre estos dos mecanismos
de reacción
tenemos aquí nuestro alumno de alquilo
terciario el amarillo es el halógeno que
está enlazado directamente con nuestro
carbono alfa y tenemos tres grupos
metidos a su alrededor uno dos y tres si
pensamos en este al uno del kilo
terciario participando en un mecanismo
de reacción sn 2 el año ni hidróxido
trata de funcionar como un núcleo filo
atacando a este carbono pero se
atraviesan estos grupos metilo
estorbosos bloqueando el paso de la
unión hidro
y entonces aquí hay demasiado
impedimento estético como para que
suceda un ataque núcleo físico en este
carbono sin embargo si pensamos en un
mecanismo de reacción de dos lo único
que tenemos que hacer es tomar un protón
de alguno de estos carbonos beta por
ejemplo este es un carbono beta y
podríamos quitar este protón pero
primero no se nos olvide que tenemos que
poder poner a estos cuatro átomos en un
mismo plano y la forma más fácil de ver
esto es con una proyección de newman
así es que rotamos esto un poquito y
hacemos que esto gire obteniendo una
conformación diferente pero ahora estos
cuatro átomos si están en el mismo plano
que es algo que necesitamos para el
mecanismo 2 y por acá es bastante fácil
para él hay un hidróxido llegar y
llevarse a este protón beta porque para
tomar este protón casi no hay un
pedimento esférico y por lo tanto el
mecanismo de reacción
es posible acabamos de ver que un alumno
de alquilo terciario si puede sufrir una
reacción de eliminación de dos y de
hecho conforme vamos pasando de alumnos
de alquilo de primario al secundario o
terciario la velocidad de la reacción de
dos va aumentando para explicar por qué
sucede esto
veamos mecanismos de reacción de dos con
sustratos secundarios y terciarios
analicemos sus productos y veamos si
podemos explicar por qué sucede pero
vamos a empezar con el terciario
ok tenemos aquí una base tenemos aquí un
protón la base se lleva este protón los
electrones de este enlace se pasan para
acá para formar un doble enlace y al
mismo tiempo los electrones de este
enlace se van con el halógeno y entonces
el producto que nos queda es éste y los
electrones de este enlace
y los que ahora están formando el doble
enlace y ahora veamos una reacción de
dos con un sustrato secundario tenemos
por aquí una base fuerte y por acá
tenemos un protón entonces llega a la
base fuerte y se lleva este protón los
electrones de este enlace se pasan para
acá para formar un doble enlace y al
mismo tiempo los electrones de este
enlace se van con el halógeno y entonces
lo que nos queda como producto de una
reacción de eliminación de dos con un
sustrato secundario se ve así y son
estos electrones los que ahora forman el
doble enlace y ahora ya que tenemos dos
productos podemos analizarlos y
compararlos aquí a la izquierda donde el
sustrato era secundario
tenemos un al que no mono sustituido
porque tenemos un solo grupo alquilo
enlazado con este carbono por otro lado
en este al que no el producto de una
reacción de dos con sustrato terciario
tenemos un al que no
sustituido porque tenemos estos dos
grupos al kilos y cuando se está
formando este doble enlace en este
mecanismo concertado los grupos al kilos
lo estabilizan y ahorita podemos
recordar el vídeo acerca de la
estabilidad de los al que nos que nos
dice que entre más sustituido sea un
doble enlace más estable es el al que no
así es que este es un al que no más
estable por lo que conforme nos vamos
moviendo de un sustrato primario a uno
secundario y a uno terciario estamos
aumentando la estabilidad de los
productos este al que no tiene dos
grupos al kilos para estabilizar el
doble enlace y éste al que no tiene un
solo grupo al kilo para estabilizar la
formación del doble enlace así es que
esa es una forma de pensar en todo esto
el por qué la velocidad de la reacción
es mayor si tenemos un sustrato
terciario ahora ahorita no hicimos esta
reacción pero definitivamente es posible
que un alumno de alquilo primario sufra
una reacción de eliminación de dos así
es que no vayas a pensar que aquí no se
puede formar un al que no
definitivamente se puede formar un al
que no y en futuros vídeos vamos a ver
ejemplos de cuando sucede esto